qui va arriver dans nos supporters de la
major a tout la croix on va regarder
toute la télé on a préparé plein de
trucs avec malik aussi ouais voilà il
est au courant
et lorsqu'on pose pas ce genre de jeu
cela match parce qu'on vous réserve une
petite surprise après seize jours
maintenant
ouais ben regarde un petit peu ce qu'on
a vu dans la télévision aujourd'hui aux
galères regarder quelques images que
l'on a vues aujourd'hui c'est la vache
regarde plus des chats qu'est ce qu'on a
vu déjà passé sa fin on a appris que oui
tiens regardez au premier rang d'un
concert de katy perry c'est bien parce
que tu payes tes places hyper cher mais
elle n'a pas le pied gauche de démarrer
et regarder qui s'est éclaté dans les
tribunes et katy perry vous allez voir
transformer il est temps pour le faire
de katy perry s'éclater et regarder
aussi dans williams à midi ils ont fait
un long sujet sur l'hygiène nos
habitudes dans la douche
il pouvait pas choisir le meilleur
médecin selon montée et fait pas bon
pour notre santé combien de fois par
jour on devrait toucher ou par semaine
nous avons aujourd'hui le docteur
saldmann impossible de choisir mieux
sinon pendant le déplacement notre
ministre du travail muriel pénicaud
parmi ses collaborateurs de ont flashé
et leurs enfants est devenu boulanger
vous savez bien que
belle saison de koh lanta au stand avec
tous les candidats les plus mythiques de
l'émission pascal à juju le cédric et
même si riesch qui a commencé
l'entraînement il est chaud visiblement
série télé l'enfant de moundir merci
messieurs folie douce et dans l'instant
on est allé dans koh lanta avec malik
dans ce port est pareil condat on a
plein de chocs ans
vas-y vas-y à tabac lors des jardins
revenir un petit peu excusez moi d'être
un peu paf dans l'actuelle m'intéresse
un petit peu ce qui se passe à ce moment
à parler du déplacement de notre
président en afrique en ce moment depuis
ce matin notre président emmanuel macron
est au burkina faso il rentre ce soir
pour pas rater le prime si mr frérot cet
après midi il répondait en direct aux
questions des burkinabé sauf qu'il a pas
réussi à placer une un peu comme jean me
fait une séance de dédicaces au papagayo
il vous plait
il y avait
s'il vous plaît je réponds à la question
de
je vais répondre à la question de
monsieur et quelques corps
et quelque part
du coup je vais finir contre
alors tu attends je vous rassure
du coup il s'en va et alors
tout est dit mais quasiment aussi
remarquer que pris dans l'ambiance le
président il a réussi à placer une
petite choré sympatico et
c'est mort
ça passe maintenant
sur des scènes aussi regarder ils ont
couvert l'événement mais ils ont trouvé
le spécialiste capable et ses chiffres
depuis 1987 s'arrête pas versé sur le
continent africain donc l'afrique n'est
plus du tout une chasse gardée
et ça il faut lactée auprès du tout
écart des roses dans des gîtes et
puisque avant de quitter france 2 david
pujadas a fait pouilles avec l'ombre de
la housse leur fils et journalistes
aussi enfant de la balle change sans
cesse du consommateur chinois pourraient
se concentrer là dessus
après deux tout cas dumas croyait du
alex goude ya plein de choses qui a dû
alex couilles c'est vrai tu es un rôle
tu es tout un démarrage alors il a dormi
chez mélenchon à la veille
patrice et bassem qui va à la banque
mais la gauche et où j'en suis mon pot
laisse un peu pousser sa taille perdu
c'est vrai a déjà bien fait italiens du
sud l'italie qu'elle aborde la poly
canada exactement ça va tu prends des
notes
j'aime pas trop la complicité que vous
avez tous les deux à quoi sert alors
extrêmement jaloux d'emblée sans rigoler
il va redescendre vous sais que je
pratique depuis plus longtemps qu au
ccif ringard c'est le droit des
pyramides posés sur des mots et balance
déroulera comme as sabah ça arrive malik
ces kits vous préférez dans la bande
proches dans la bande
attention tu as un rendez vous en terre
inconnue en mars et m'occupe de télé a
dit la belle isabelle errot garçon
regarde c'est un gars a dit isabelle un
garçon qui aime bien eddy mitchell il
est pas là ce soir est la banane à
ouidah l'uac à nivelles à elle est pas
mal
ah ouais il est pas mal à l'aise projet
pierre bénite et mettrait demain à pas
mal pour toi
ouais tu vas être là demain cc fia
j'aime tout le monde nous regarde tous
les soirs elle qui fait des taxis 5
alors ça y est ça sort qu'en taxi sans
que ça sort le 7 avril à marseille 11
avril en france et d'ailleurs à ce
propos tu sais que les marseillais
t'adore moi j'adore les marseillais mars
et adore on a tourné là-bas on était
très semaine à marseille
ils me demandent des nouvelles à chaque
fois on va cyril et je voulais demander
ce soir en direct devant tout le monde
ouais une prise d'otage est en train de
faire vas-y est-ce que tu serais prêt à
faire la veille de la sortie de taxi
donc le dise le 10 avril les 10 avril
ouais en direct de marseille touche pas
à mon père si avec j'avais tout dit et
tout ça donc tu me donnes alors les
infos donc les infos qu'est-ce que six
services avril très bien à marseille 1-1
marseille travaux ont inspiré localiser
touche pas à mon poste la première fois
de l'histoire de plus pas mon poste est
localisé ok voilà ça va te coûter quand
même de ces chanteurs les coins
on est ric-rac on ne compte pas tu crois
que la production du film peut faire un
petit truc à clermont ferrand on fait
quoi non content moi bien est ce qu on
le fait ou pas touche pas à mon taxi à
marseille écoute moi bien non sans
prendre la décision tout de suite où tu
vois bien c'est fait on va à marseille
l'oreille sur bakary tu seras là euro
doivent faire le malin le mois on y va
ça y est c'est fait c'est fait j'allais
absent à voir j'ai un petit conte aaron
avec le petit chauve la cap a tenu sa
promesse
voilà c'est moi vous êtes dans le public
ou mais le gars on dirait un gars qui
parle du public en fait dans mes seins
et oui qu'est ce qui se passe des tapas
l'animent
ah non non mon brave franck gastambide
voilà on y est dans le film
voilà j'ai même veine on n'est pas s'il
voulait que ça marche c'est bon pas la
peine de m'appeler pour le ciss très
bien l'avouer oui le josserand que c'est
la suite de pattaya je veux bien qu'on
aille à pattaya aussi la troisième
bataille avec vous l'a pas dit merci
mais n'est-il pas mal peut-être pas ce
n'est pas la bonne heure ce n'est pas le
times il ajouté avec malice qu'on est
allé directement dans koh lanta wallace
et un skate que je me suis fait chier a
monté tout la preuve l'affairé isabelle
morini-bosc barret s'accroissant pas
concernés hier franck gastambide par aaa
ah ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
il mais ils nous envoient des cuillères
à café qui le blond ouais c'est km on
est allé faire un tour dans koh lanta
regardez ce que ça donne c'est pas
quand vous voyez que vous avez été
capable de ramener deux masses malgré ça
on s'est tu perds ton
que nous vous réagissez daniel qui
pensent à moi je te respecte c'est pas
ça le truc c'est que les gens y viennent
ils sont jamais faits des preuves
physiques jamais fait d'épreuves
sportives
pardon pardon et tâter du sportif yoga
bikram spa du sport pardon à ma mère je
n'aime pas je vais [ __ ] je vais
chercher l'urne et je procède tout de
suite au dépouillement
m vous prenez votre sac aller récupérer
votre flambeau et venez me rejoindre
montagne et je suis désolé moi je veux
pas tout revoir parce que je suis ici
j'ai pas mangé depuis trois mois j'ai
galère pas pardon denis déjà c'est un
tricheur
le sac est remplie d'écureuil à ne plus
savoir qu'en faire alors pardon mais
n'importe quoi y'a rien dans l'ombre le
ton sac avec n'importe qui c'est c'est
quoi mais c'est du manioc ça c'est du
majorque n'a ouvert et ça c'est quoi
c'est pas de la pâte à tartiner peu
mieux mais ça c'est l'huile de palme
c'est pour les palmiers ça maintenant
courteau que tu prends le supporte plus
sur le camp c'est bien ça mais passons
ensuite habite la vase et on va s'aimer
4 60 à 4 va baser t'inquiète pas vous
avez le plus de voix qu'est ce que vous
avez envie de leur dire quoi daniel moi
je veux dire un truc vraiment ça me
tient à coeur parce que je pensais
qu'avec lépine toul où on était une
tribu liés bernard la tête de ma mère
chaud tu habites il a vu ma mère chez oh
tu habites ça sert à rien de s'énerver
comme ça quand on nous parle du général
leclerc un deuxième est incubé 28-16
c'est à celui qui parle le plus fort qui
a raison merci pouvoir voir wayne et
envoie mort voir
je pars vous allez bien galéré moi je
vais aller manger de la viande bonne
journée bonne soirée société corrompue
ça n'avait rien de personnel ou au
canada bonne continuation et auxerre
on a notre chance l'actualité c'est ma
grande passion avec la rumba bien sûr et
là dans la rumba et non moins d'un mois
il sort quoi le prochain star wars d'or
oies et vu comment jean pierre elkabbach
broadway commence à me faire chier avec
leur anglais merci taxis ces taxis bah
oui voilà bien sûr c'est fait et vu
comment regarder pire que vous et jean
pierre elkabbach vu comment il prononce
dark vador j'ai l'impression pour luke
skywalker c'est dur oui ce qui n'est pas
du tout believe ok c'est une superbe
intelligence au service du côté obscur
de la force
dark vador
l'équipe de france de la coupe davis
était en direct dans le jt de france 3
hier personne ne sait où et yannick noah
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'ils
gardent pas bien les secrets dans
l'équipe
c'est vrai quoi la famille tend à nous
faire tout seul que fait votre capitaine
n'aura jamais le des fois y'a doigts et
chanter bois il fume suis roulé mais mon
préféré c'est dire mais regarde sur la
chaîne parlementaire on assiste à un
vote en direct maintenant ça arrive à et
une députée qui est contre contre une
loi est tellement près c'est qu'elle
s'est trahi du parlement devant un avis
défavorable à l'amendement est rejeté
qu'ils aient oublié de faire voter il va
sur le direct carla et c'est le mâle
blanc est mignon mignon plus jeune âge
noté la chronique bon j'ai d'autres j'ai
vécu ma télé je l ai aussi les très
bientôt
parce qu'hier j'ai regardé le caté au
quizz vous connaissez soja théo j'adore
c'est sur kto tv
c'est le jeu de quiz du chrétien en
marche c'est le seul jour où les
candidats ont pas envie d'être là à côté
je cache pas des chiffres et des lettres
c'est le morning live ça sera déjà trop
tard car ils auront avancé il
ce sont deux candidats dans la foi et
dans la bonne humeur et sur kto les
candidats sont mous là sous la
contrainte tellement que en arrivant
c'est pas la grosse ambiance non au
moment du départ non plus je ne cache
pas c'était pour vous merci beaucoup
d'être venus si vous voulez passer un
bonjour un coucou c'est nous pas mon
genre non si dans nos questions pour un
champion on a vu le candidat qui
répètent les mauvaises réponses données
avant il se dit qu'à force ça va passer
tête
annick lee mille et mille en groupes
opposés mais et non non ça me fait chaud
sûrement mais carole ganesh dont le dieu
aux mille mois son mot à dire olivier
minne il nous en a fait une spéciale il
a fait l'impasse sur l'acte une valérie
bègue apparemment et c'est très gênant
la merde
monsieur a aussi et bien vous vous étiez
voir quoi je respecte et ça a été une
très bonne
vous souhaitez une bonne amie la passat
a pas sa passagère franchement ça passe
ça passe
tiens on s'est incrusté dans des jeux
télé aussi avec malik vous allez voir ça
va bien sûr on peut regarder ça de la
paix rue ganne la moustache et à
l'humour robin vous voici la lettre f
fac similé maxime1010 rouge et un rouge
la honda les voitures phacochères f
assez au ch er festival het val commun
angoulême la rochelle outil d'animation
butin avant la péta piketty humaine
comme du général [ __ ]
martin attention ludovic connait-il oui
ou non toute la partie de votre physique
en complément peu plus souvent
oui les couilles
c'est mon humour c'est mon délire à eux
les amis avant des frères aussi qu'on a
fait avec on va pas et foutrement avec
le supporter numéro 1 de l'om ou
ailleurs l'aï d'ailleurs demain il y
aura touche pas à mon poste est juste
derrière touche pas à mon poste juste
après direct pg 3 way sur sur ces 8 mai
où elle et gaby ouais les gars ça tombe
comme un bonbon marbre et on savait pas
quoi dire oui bon rené malleville ses
supporters d'humeur
il sera dans taxi malheureusement il est
un peu comme moi comme tous les
supporters marseillais on n'a plus trop
et 28 de voir marseille
papa tu vois tu dis pas que des
conneries bouge à l'étoile eh bien
regardez entre chopin c'est qu'on
n'arrive même plus à le dire tellement
n'y est pas battus sans rooney malvin la
queen c'est au tour du chambon le podium
pour faire les guides robe qu'elle ait
plus jamais de lampes la ligue mais à la
nation qu'il fait là lui l'autre là
l'humour
laly les shadoks donc c'est au programme
sophie davant est de plus en plus en
mode balech ou alors c'était son quart
d'heure sans filtre à elle défend un
savoir-faire en france à savoir faire
anciens mais aussi technologiques
voilà très bien séduit beaucoup philippe
en direct de là où il est et dans la
série régis et un croc aujourd'hui régis
aimiez à la chasse rjc regarde jamais
derrière lui
c'est où c'est incroyable
signez là on voulait voir les frères way
la veine des loges allez la bkb taloche
létard et voilà c'est parti on arrête
les gens dans la rue et dès qu'ils nous
répondent dans se déguise comme deux
fois plus dur des deux déguisement a
trouvé assez pixar qu'est ce que vous
pensez les transports en commun de paris
le métro héros pratique et vous êtes de
paris
pas du tout et votre frère il en pense
quoi mon frère aucune idée grosso modo
la même chose
ben spies enfin il ya de votre heure et
voulant penses quoi
la chance était des triplés en fait nous
donc série 5 la baisse c'est le métro
les bus jacques chirac est mécontent
cabaye a rien eu et votre frère il en
pense quoi
j'ai pas de frère tce sortait de prison
là alors on société vous n'allez pas
tarder à y retourner
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
personnellement je trouve que les
transports parisiens sont deux de très
bon niveau est le frère de l'autre elle
en pense quoi
et le frère de mon file en france à peu
près la même chose
ça va très bien en chantier voila on a
toujours ce soir oui merci
comme d'habitude pour buffalo forcément
ça c'est passé vite
aya que les francs-maçons et koné à
téloche cj manatee sa pyramide qu'est ce
que vous pensez des transports en commun
parisiens
j'habite au canada et je trouve que les
transports parisienne est fantastique
c'est vite et en santé j'adore la soeur
de votre sort qu'est ce qu'elle en pense
keanu pitt assure de votre sang elle en
pense quoi
pourquoi nous les adaptons famille
n'existe que deux cocottes cliff la flou
ok y'a 06 ou piggott
bonjour pays de goethe
en fin de l'année